ce qui se passe, ils commencent à
se manifester et je ne peux pas les arrêter
quand tu penses que je suis sur le point de faire
quelque chose qui pourrait briser l'univers,
je sais que tu le gères par nous,
nous devons les renvoyer,
tu ne l'es pas  tu vas m'enlever ça
tu voles dans l'obscurité pour
combattre des fantômes, qu'est-ce que tu veux dire, ils
meurent tous en combattant Spider-Man, je suis désolé gamin
ouais moi aussi, non, il
doit y avoir un autre moyen là-bas, ce
n'est pas le cas
Spider-Man ne rentre pas à la maison le 17 décembre, je t'ai
sous-estimé Peter, est-ce que je sais que tu as l'air d'
avoir de la concurrence,
nous avons commencé à avoir des visiteurs
dans leur univers, ils meurent tous en combattant
Spider-Man, je suis désolé gamin ouais moi
aussi, je ne suis pas obligé de le
faire.  sois une autre victoire, il n'y a pas ce qui
se passe, ils commencent à
s'en sortir, je ne peux pas l'arrêter,
Spider-Man ne rentre pas chez lui exclusivement au
cinéma le 17 décembre,
tu n'es pas Peter Parker, je suis tellement confus
en ce moment,
ce sort que tu  acheté a commencé à
attirer des visiteurs de tous les univers
le multivers est réel
ils meurent tous en combattant Spider-Man il
doit y avoir un autre moyen, ils ne
représentent pas un danger pour notre univers
c'est entièrement de ma faute je ne peux pas sauver
tout le monde
Spiderman non  je rentre chez moi au cinéma le
17 décembre depuis que j'ai été mordu par
cette araignée,
je n'ai eu qu'une semaine où ma vie m'a
semblé normale, c'est quand tu as
découvert Peter
ce sort que tu avais bâclé, il a commencé à
attirer des visiteurs de tous les univers,
ce qui se passe, ils  tu commences à
arriver et je ne peux pas l'arrêter,
Spider-Man ne rentre pas chez toi quand tu
penses, je suis sur le point de faire quelque chose
qui pourrait briser l'univers, dirige-le par
nous la prochaine fois au cinéma le 17 décembre,
c'est Peter  laisse un message ouais Peter,
c'est heureux
qui sont ces gars, hein,
l'un des gars a fait de la boue, qu'est-ce qui se passe,
rappelle-moi
quand j'ai arrêté ce sort, nous avons commencé à
recevoir des visiteurs de tous les
univers, le
multivers est réel, c'était
un dinosaure
dans les salles en décembre  le 17
tu